[Music]
on this tuesday night out of afghanistan
but now in limbo you're hurt broken
you're really hopeless this former
interpreter for the canadian forces and
his family made it to ukraine but can't
get to canada how long more we will win
in this situation
vaccine politics families torn apart by
misinformation it's so hurtful when a
family member makes a decision
based on their socio or political or
religious beliefs the impact in one part
of alberta where only 56 percent of
people are vaccinated plus one of the
worst public health failures a scathing
report on the uk's early response to
covet 19.
and lego for everyone building blocks
for a gender inclusive society
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with whether the world is
prepared to help afghanistan now that
the taliban is back in charge world
leaders including canada's prime
minister took part in a virtual summit
today facing pressure to pour more money
into the country to keep it from
economic collapse afghanistan has long
been completely dependent on foreign aid
which was frozen when the taliban took
over now banks are running out of money
food is in short supply a humanitarian
crisis is looming today the eu pledged a
1.4 billion dollar aid package the u.s
president says aid should be provided
through independent international
organizations and not directly to the
ruling taliban which most countries have
refused to recognize
in august canada pledged 50 million
dollars in humanitarian aid to
afghanistan it's also promised to
resettle 40 000 vulnerable afghans about
2400 have arrived so far
others have managed to make it to a
third country but are now stuck in limbo
one of them is a former interpreter for
the canadian military his family
survived a daring escape from kabul only
to become stranded in ukraine waiting
for word from the canadian government
crystal gomanson is in ukraine with our
top story tonight
everyone around little two-year-old
muhammad works to keep him smiling and
entertained
the happy sounds bounce off the hotel
walls lightening the otherwise heavy
mood
even just for a few minutes at a time we
are heart broken we are really hopeless
his father javid ahmed hakmal in his
donated canada's wonderland sweater
dreams of a life in canada but right now
it feels so far out of reach
yeah many times like my wife my kids my
mother
many times like my mother is crying my
wife's crying that in which situation we
are
how long more we will win in this
situation
and his 11 family members were rescued
from kabul with another family not by
the government of canada or the canadian
forces for whom he served as a
translator from 2009 to june 2011
but by the globe and mail
the hawk malls happened to be with the
newspaper's translator when ukrainian
special forces conducted an extraction
in august we were so happy we thought
that now we are saved safe but not free
do you know if they have all your
paperwork and it's just me being
processed or are you missing paperwork
do they tell you this is the thing i
every time request from them that please
give me a logical answer i even did my
biometrics in afghanistan
already embassy was open i did this i
received my health insurance papers from
the m from the canada for the kids even
i don't know for how long more i will be
waiting the family has been left
languishing here in kyiv for so long
that their ukraine humanitarian visas
have expired now they're fearful to even
leave the hotel to go for a walk in case
the police stop them many times i'm
telling my kids my wife my brothers that
please being be in room don't go outside
a police catch you so this is again a
big problem it's not just the safety of
his family with him but those he was
forced to leave back in afghanistan he's
been told regularly about relatives
being harassed because of his work as an
interpreter all the while he's simply
trying to scrounge up money to buy food
medicine and diapers the hotel for now
is being covered by the globe and mail
like i'm begging
calling to every friend to everyone i
know that please help me i'm in a very
bad situation a bad situation that leads
to dark moments very difficult believe
me if there was someone instead of me he
would already
shoot herself because it is very
difficult
until the family's application to come
to canada is approved they have no
access to canadian government supports
and because they're not claiming asylum
in ukraine they're not eligible for any
local services either
leaving them in limbo waiting
and hoping that soon their reason for
smiling and laughing
will be more than make believe
crystal gamansen global news
keefe
tomorrow we'll have more on the hakmal
family and hear from a former canadian
government employee who says someone
should be fired for how refugee
applications are being handled
the canadian major general who is
fighting to get his job back as head of
logistics for canada's covid19 vaccine
rollout has lost a first legal round
today the federal court refused to hear
the case of major general danny forte
who was removed from his post after a
complaint of sexual misconduct surfaced
last spring michael couture explains the
ruling and where the case might go from
here
major general danny fartain's lawyer
says her client is disappointed with the
federal court's decision and he's still
convinced he was removed from his
position without due process he was
not afforded procedural fairness and
that the decision to remove him was
unreasonable so
he remains steadfast in that
forte is requesting he be reinstated as
the head of canada's covet 19 vaccine
distribution task force after he was
abruptly removed from the high profile
position in may it came following an
allegation of sexual misconduct against
forte
dating back more than 30 years the
federal court didn't rule on the merits
of the case but rather on how fatten
chose to fight it saying he should have
used the military's internal grievance
process instead justice anne-marie
mcdonald sided with the government
writing in her decision quote the
decision to remove him from the public
health agency of canada position
was the acting chief of the defense
staff's decision to make
if that did not happen the grievance
process can address that failure end
quote
forte's lawyer contends that process is
too time consuming pointing to a recent
report from former supreme court justice
morris fish who described the military
grievance system as broken with a major
backlog of cases besides rodriguez
argued fortn's quick removal was purely
political we named the prime minister of
canada as one of the decision makers so
in essence sending this to grievance
would be saying that the grievance
process which is an internal military
process would have authority to quash
the decision of the prime minister of
canada that to us does not make any
sense the defense minister isn't
commenting on the decision but this
labor lawyer believes it's still an open
question whether forte was afforded due
process there should still be for
example the opportunity to allow the
person to make submissions
or to be heard and saying you know to
give them an opportunity to say here's
why you shouldn't remove me from my
secondment while his civil lawyers
consider appealing this ruling forte
will be back in criminal court november
5th where he faces one count of sexual
assault which dates back to 1988 while
attending royal military college in
sinjar quebec
donna
all right mike lukatura thanks surging
kovit 19 cases in new brunswick have led
hospitals there to go on red alert it
means non-urgent procedures will be
postponed or greatly reduced there are
now more than 1 000 active infections in
new brunswick 27 people are in intensive
care 82 percent of them are unvaccinated
the fourth wave of the covid19 pandemic
is hitting our province very hard
we are seeing a surge in new infections
to levels that we have not experienced
at any point since the pandemic began
this is likely to continue for some time
in alberta and saskatchewan new data
suggests the fourth wave may have hit a
peak though gatherings over thanksgiving
weekend could change that a year ago the
october long weekend marked the
beginning of the second wave across the
whole country this year there is more
exhaustion and anxiety in some places
because so many hospitals are over
capacity dozens are dying every week and
staff are completely drained heather
urix west reports
trudy ballard and rod column's
thanksgiving weekend was filled with
grief their father 85 year old jim
collum died last week of covet 19. my
dad was the kind of guy that
would give
anything to anyone personally i feel i
couldn't have had a better dad his
children pleaded with him to get
immunized but like so many others in his
central alberta community column was
deeply opposed to the vaccine
in his rural conservative part of the
province vaccine coverage is only about
56 percent there's
a lot of attitudes that the government
is intrusive
and this is just another action on the
government's part to intrude in
individual lives
so dad felt that but that lack of
protection has only helped the delta
variant spread people are dying in
alberta at three times canada's national
per capita rate the death rate is more
than four times higher in saskatchewan
it's simply a percentage game and there
are so many people with the virus now
that even a small percentage of people
getting sick or losing their life will
translate to a large number
when we're talking about tens of
thousands of people that are actively
infected
across the prairies hospitals remain
under tremendous strain and there are
fears that the recent thanksgiving
holiday could lead to yet another surge
i think right now the key piece again is
our icu capacity so
um we're at a point literally i think uh
you know we're probably like
a few patients away from having to
trigger
you know significant measures in terms
of getting people out of the province
it's why trudy and her brother rod
decided to share their family's grief
hopeful their loss might convince
someone else to see past their ideology
and get the vaccine i think it's so
hurtful when a family member makes a
decision
based on their socio or political or
religious beliefs that put those beliefs
ahead of their own family because for us
family is more important heather urex
west global news near olds alberta
health officials in british columbia are
concerned about the situation in the
province's north hospitals there are
unable to meet the demand 55 critical
care patients have now been transferred
to hospitals in other health regions of
bc of those patients 43 have coveted and
42 of them are not fully vaccinated
for those people walking around
unvaccinated
who might be in those critical care beds
in two or three weeks i say to them now
is the time surely now is the time to
get vaccinated with the whole health
care system all in in support now is the
time to get vaccinated
the province is considering additional
health measures and looking at booster
shots for some communities
and as of today all employees in
long-term care and assisted living
facilities in bc need to be vaccinated
if workers have not had at least one
dose they will be placed on leave
without pay those who have had a single
dose will have to undergo daily rapid
testing and will have to get a second
shot within 35 days of their first the
province also updated its mandatory mass
mandate for indoor public spaces to
include children aged 5 and up
it's being called one of the uk's worst
public health failures coming up the
damning report on the government's early
handling of the pandemic plus russia's
deadliest day the rising tide of cases
and the faltering vaccination drive
kovit 19 is taking a staggering toll on
russia that country saw 973 no new
coveted related deaths on tuesday
breaking another record set almost every
other day so far this month the russian
government blames the surge in cases on
a slow vaccination rate just 29 percent
of russia's population is fully
vaccinated despite that the kremlin is
still ruling out any plans for a
nationwide lockdown leaving it up to
regional authorities to enforce
restrictions
the united kingdom has had its share of
missteps in handling covid19 especially
at the start of the pandemic
now a skating report released by british
lawmakers paints a bleak picture
including the government's apparent
decision to allow covid to spread
throughout the population costing
thousands of lives
redmond shannon has more
in march 2020 six weeks after the
british government's first meeting with
scientific advisors on covet 19 prime
minister boris johnson wasn't too
worried about social distancing
i was at a hospital the other night
where i think there were a few there
were actually a few coronavirus patients
and i shook hands with everybody on live
tv he even mused about the strategy of
allowing the virus to run free a month
later johnson was admitted to intensive
care with covet 19 and almost died
after a week in which the nhs has saved
my life a new uk parliamentary
committee's report criticizes his
government's lack of urgency in
responding to the outbreak and mistakes
made by government scientists it notes
how the uk went into a national lockdown
a week or more after many other european
countries that despite evidence from
china and italy that the virus was
highly infectious
an analysis by imperial college london
has estimated locking down a week
earlier could have saved between 16 000
and 36 000 lives the report says these
decisions rank as one of the most
important public health failures the
united kingdom has ever experienced i
don't understand why you don't want to
apologize well there are lessons to
learn but the point is that we took
decisions based on the science it turns
out that they weren't following the
science and and
the scientific method
such as it was of of developing
uh their the advice to politicians was
deeply flawed uh highly secretive uh
badly informed from experts in some
regards professor gabriel scali is a
member of an independent group of
scientists monitoring the pandemic in
britain he says the government was more
concerned about data than it was about
action the major
scientific advisory group on emergencies
didn't have
public health physicians on it at all
the report also criticizes huge failings
at care homes where more than 40 000
people died in less than two months one
success it focuses on is the early
procurement of vaccines and support for
the development of the astrazeneca
vaccine a workhorse across the uk a full
independent public inquiry into covert
19 is set to begin in the spring redmond
shannon global news london
there's some new advice from the u.s
about taking low-dose aspirin to prevent
a heart attack if you don't have a
history of heart attack and stroke you
shouldn't be starting on aspirin just
because you reached a certain age
mounting evidence shows daily aspirin
use can cause serious harms and risk
increases with age under new guidelines
doctors are being told not to prescribe
aspirin to adults aged 60 and older
since the risk of bleeding outweighs any
potential benefits
still ahead watch your head a bc woman
gets a rude awakening from the cosmos
[Music]
a rescue operation is underway in the
philippines after a tropical cyclone
triggered flash flooding and landslides
trapping people in their homes at least
11 have died the storm drenched villages
on the island of luzon
6 500 people were forced from their
homes and the storm is now barreling
over the south china sea towards vietnam
lava has led to more evacuations on the
spanish island of la palma
authorities ordered 700 people to leave
their homes today after lava began
flowing toward their community more than
1100 buildings have been destroyed since
the volcano began erupting three weeks
ago
a woman in golden bc says a meteorite
nearly hit her while she was fast asleep
at home
this is how close the rock came to ruth
hamilton's pillow when it crashed
through her roof earlier this month
police first suspected the debris came
from a construction site on a nearby
highway but after further investigation
they concluded it fell from the sky
during a meteor shower hamilton
thankfully wasn't hurt and she plans to
keep that rock as a memento
up next a toy industry giant promises
new building blocks to break gender
stereotypes
toys and kids go hand in hand but even
in 2021 there are stereotypes in toy
stores so lego funded a survey that
found 76 percent of parents would
recommend lego for their sons and only
24 percent would recommend it to their
daughters as mike gerlay reports lego
decided it's time to build a new model
for inclusiveness
at its core lego has always been pretty
basic a brick is a brick is a brick
after all
but somewhere along the line the
marketing became more
he's targeted lego maniac no longer was
lego for everyone it was for zach or for
emma designed for boys or for girls at
the beauty shop emma is styled and ready
to go well the company that builds lego
commissioned a study and found fault all
around
they need to do better but parents they
found are far more likely to steer girls
towards stereotypes dress up in cooking
and boys towards sports and coding
toronto's brick labs wants no part of
that they offer stem classes and camps
for kids with a focus on interests over
gender which they sometimes have to
explain it started by the parents to be
honest they come in and they'll be like
do you have girl classes not just
engineering classes do you have a
robotics class um
you know for my son but then it's like
do you have an art class for my daughter
so dated gender norms are to blame as is
marketing and maybe we parents and kids
are influenced by it i didn't like the
lego friends because it's a girls thing
the study shows boys and girls worry
about being teased for playing with the
wrong toy
we don't want to have to gender police
our kids we don't want other kids gender
policing our kids and it's hard to
change culture like sure i'll just go
out and change everyone's point of view
that's pretty hard but you know what a
company can very easily
not put boys lego on their website
and just put lego
yeah and let kids build and dream free
from the hang-ups of adults microlight
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen there have
been some stunning northern lights this
season thanks to a solar flare so we
leave you with a spectacular display of
aurora borealis over alberta please
email us your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]